Matros I enjoy the old chess books that
I've read and I reread I really enjoyed
the chess games that really are very
very impactful and I want you to I want
to take you back to a nostalgic time in
1974 1974 that's a long long time ago I
know it is but I was a young man and I
was just starting it was my second year
as playing chess and at the time Bobby
Fischer was world champion and everybody
was wondering you know like where's
Bobby
what is Bobby Fischer doing he hadn't
played chess publicly since 1972 he
hadn't so much just pushed upon and in
the meanwhile there was a series of
tournaments and matches to determine who
would be his Challenger and in 1974
Anatoly Karpov and Viktor Korchnoi
played a match 24 game match the winner
was the first to score 12 and a half
points in the winner would be Bobby
Fischer's Challenger whoo and this game
that I'm about to show you was super
important in fact it was critical for
that match the final score in the match
was 12 and a half 11 and a half and
Anatoly Karpov won and became challenger
to Bobby Fischer nobody had heard from
Bobby Fischer and then suddenly and out
of the blue there was a letter that was
published in chess Life magazine it was
the magazine and as the magazine of the
United States Chess Federation and Bobby
Fischer did not want to play a twenty
four game match like he played with
Boris Spassky Bobby Fischer wanted to
play a match with his Challenger the
first player to win 10 games 10 games
draws not counting would be the winner
of the match
if the champion scored nine points
he couldn't lose his title because the
best the Challenger could get is ninety
nine on a when both players scored nine
wins each the match would be would be
declared a draw the prize money would be
paid equally and the champion would
retain his title the feed a did not
accept Bobby Fischer's proposal instead
they said the first to win six games the
player who first won six games would win
the match and in case of five five you
play to a finish you play to the next
decisive game Bobby didn't accept that
new proposal and so Bobby forfeited the
title to Anatoly Karpov anyway this game
is a really for me an all-time favorite
when you think about the middle game for
a moment you start to think what are
some of the most exciting chess games
that you've ever played or that you can
remember for me it was always when both
sides were attacking one another's King
and so it was like a tightrope and both
players had to play defense and offense
simultaneously so any of those games
where players castled on opposite sides
either white castles King side black
Queen side or vice versa the games were
unusually sharp and in those types of
middle games which ever side you're
playing you really have to stay on the
offensive if you try to to go into some
kind of defensive shell it normally
doesn't work and so here for me is one
of my favorite all-time favorite games
in fact this game is extraordinarily
unusual for somebody to win a game of
chess would you agree that player has to
make a mistake
yeah if you played a perfect game do you
think you could lose it makes a strange
question right if you played perfectly
and still lost what does that mean maybe
you didn't play perfectly in my opinion
white played perfectly in this game and
there was only one mistake one and only
one mistake that black made he lost the
game because of it in shape black loss
let's see so first of all Anatoly Karpov
Viktor Korchnoi game to the 1974 feat a
finals championship candidates match
efore when Anatoly Karpov was rising to
the level of Challenger he his he almost
exclusively played efore and when he was
world champion he most throughout his
career played efore that was his move
when Anatoly Karpov lost his title to
Garry Kasparov in 1985 he almost stopped
playing
efore altogether it was really quite a
transition so e4 c5 a Sicilian defense
Knight f3 d6 d4 so all of these moves
are very very standard the open Sicilian
Knight f6 attacking the pawn on e4
Knight to c3 okay
so in this position where tens of
thousands of Grandmaster games exist
there's a wide variety of choices black
could develop his knight he could play
ISA 'kz he can play a6 the night Orff
and finally he can play g6 the dragon
the dragon variation and so
uh what do you think huh why do they
call this the dragon defense Martin well
that's building a fortress but it
doesn't really explain why it's a dragon
are you what do you think yeah because
if you look at the structure it looks
like a dragon and the idea is that
dragon players love to fianchetto the
bishop so they can breathe fire across
the diagonal Martin well yeah you have
to just kind of put that put the pawns
and you kind of imagine so like here's a
head and so because it's kind of a body
and the tail the head of the dragon in
the body well you got to use your
imagination
okay g6 Bishop e3 this is very standard
opening theory white develops his bishop
as quick as pieces as quickly as
possible and black plays Bishop g7 yeah
so here there's a trap there's a very
important trap that you should never
fall for because you've heard you've
you're now being shown the trap so why
is Knight g4 a bad move and Bishop b5
check and then if I block the check with
my Bishop Queen takes g4 winning a piece
thank you very much
taking advantage of the fact that the
bishop on d7 is pinned by this Bishop
black would lose a piece I fell for that
trap as black but I only fell for it
once okay it doesn't fall for twice I
was proud of myself that I only fell for
it once okay so Bishop e3 Bishop to g7
developing very clever and now f3 okay
so with this move white basically he
strengthens his pawn on e4 gives the
pawn on e4 protection and stops the move
Knight g4 okay so after f3 Knight came
to c6 developing Queen to d2 castles
these were all standard opening
theoretical moves at the time and I
remember being very interested in
opening theory why did they do this why
don't they do that what's wrong with
that what's wrong with that and it
finally took a while but it finally
dawned on me that it was all theory was
basically another way of saying
experience there were thousands of Grand
Master's games and each game gave us
more experience more knowledge and it
was only through the test of time that
this theory became developed and
codified and I remember the first how
many of you saw encyclopedia of chess
openings then fine gold don't raise your
hand
yeah you saw and you saw how thick the
encyclopedia was under at the time I
like to play the dragon as black and I
was afraid only of this move Bishop to
c4 they called this the Yugoslavia tack
and Andy soul test gave a lot of
analysis to it as well as practical play
Grandmaster Andy Salta so for me I don't
know why the yoga Slaven the Soviets
always got their name on everything that
should be like a Psaltis variation not
the Yugoslavia a ssin but this move was
a very crafty move because again we're
talking about
on offense and defense why does planning
to put his king on the queenside Black
has already committed his King to the
King side and this bishop comes so on
the one hand as an attacker look at
where blacks king is and on the other
hand as a defender the bishop could drop
back to b3 and when your castled that
Bishop helps protect your king your King
would be super protected anyway all of
this is very well known and Bishop to d7
developing okay
so what is about to take place is a
really a strategic fight at the highest
levels between two of the very best
grandmasters in the world and what this
move does is it prepares to bring a rope
to the C file which is like an open
highway to White's King as soon as
White's King is over on the key on the
castle position the rook on c8 will bear
down the C file on the other hand notice
that the King side is closed there's no
open files for white to attack blacks
King so white is going to have to open
up the Kings side while black is going
to play down the Queen side so Bishop d7
h4 and this was a very strong attacking
move and Bobby Fischer was once asked
the question what about the dragon
variation and Bobby said h4 h5 sac sac
mate so it was very dismissive of the
dragon as a viable defensive system and
Bobby very often used this device of h4
and h5 to open up blacks King side and
he won some nice games h4
rook c8 what could be sweeter black
develops his rook and he has an implied
threat against the bishop he on c-4 he's
intending to take this Knight and
opening a discovered attack against the
bishop the bishop drops back Bishop III
so for me this was a very principled
position that I tried to study egg I
mean it was a little bit above my
knowledge or experience but I understood
that blacks King is pretty protected but
white is going to play very powerfully
on the Kings side and black somehow he
needs to be able to develop threats
against White's King I thought that the
move Viktor Korchnoi played was the best
move in the position which was 95 the
knight comes to the center of the board
and he sets up the idea of Knight C for
attacking the Queen and Bishop and
blocking the bishop on b3 so 95 very
nice and again the players are still in
the theory so white continues castles
bringing his King and shelter and black
continues Knight C for white decided so
white decides that this Knight on c4 if
he moves the Queen
this Knight will capture this Bishop
once this Bishop is captured
there's no Bishop h6 there's no getting
to blacks King white needs this bishop
in order to trade off the dark squares
and to weaken black's castle position so
white decides to capture Bishop takes
rook takes
and now we see this move h5 so White's
idea is very clear he just wants to take
this pawn and open up his rook Viktor
Korchnoi was known as a fearless
fearless fighter and he would walk
through the Gobi Desert for a pawn so
Viktor very happily snapped this bond
white sack whites act upon the best
refutation to a sacrifice is to accept
it so thought Viktor Korchnoi Knight
takes h5 g4 oh I wanted to say because
this game made such a powerful
impression on my young mind I began to
think that maybe here I could improve on
courts noise play because I wanted to
play the black position I was thinking
that coronally maybe should have played
the move Queen a five and after trades
to take with the g6 pawn the reason why
I was thinking that this might be the
proper way to play is because later I
could use the move rook on f8 to f7 to
help defend the h7 pawn if necessary it
makes it an awkward impression because
the pawn structure is no longer a dragon
it's like somebody just threw you know
blew a hole in the belly of the Dragon
but if you as black can hold your king
sight for a long while your counter play
on the Queen side becomes very
pronounced so I tried this and funnily
enough I was pretty successful I don't
know of anybody else tried it in the
meanwhile Korchnoi captured the pawn
Knight takes h5 white attack the knight
g4 driving back the knight to f6 and
notice that this
also this movie oh sorry excuse me this
move g4 also sets up an opportunity for
Queen h2 if needed
using the H file okay
Knight f6 and then this at the time
Knight de 2 was considered the most
challenging offensive move because it
combines offense and defense if you will
the idea is that in some cases if you
play Bishop h6 right away what dragon
players love to do is the following kind
of thing Bishop takes h6
Queen takes h6 rook takes c3 this is
considered a really really good exchange
sacrifice by black the idea is that
after B takes c3 the Queen comes out to
a5 so notice that the Queen now attacks
this pawn on a2 as well as this pawn on
c3 it also makes it very nice there are
many many times that white plays the
sacrifice Knight f5 so the idea is you
want to threaten checkmate on g7 and
there are many times that this Queen
it's very good to be able to play Bishop
takes and this Queen can come across the
fifth-ranked so anatoly karpov did not
play Bishop h6 he first played this
offensive move and defensive move the
Knight d4 comes back to e2 defensive we
understand it further protects this
knight on c3 offensive we don't
understand that comes in a moment knight
de - ok
so far so good the Queen Cubs what did I
do
I did something wrong didn't like me
Queen comes out to a5 very nice black
prepares to double his rooks
on the open sea a half open sea file
maybe he'll sacrifice two exchanges whoo
go rook takes Knight takes rook takes
again we don't know maybe he'll just
double rooks and then go beef I'd be for
chasing away the night and capturing
this pawn on c2 we don't know what we do
know is White has to play very very
precisely because blacks attack is
coming super fast okay Bishop h6 so with
this move Bishop h6 I always kind of
thought of these moves as a slaying the
dragon or trading off the dragon bishop
these were this move was very irritating
for me and very often in a lot of my
games I would sacrifice the exchange I
thought that my bishop was more useful
for protecting my king then the rook as
you can tell I probably lost a lot a lot
more games than I won sacrificing the
exchange but I was in love with the
dragon and that wasn't that was a common
device however in this case Viktor
Korchnoi after Bishop h6 he captured
Bishop takes Queen takes rook over okay
so a moment ago I mentioned that this
move was both defensive and offensive
what did I mean now we start to see that
if it's white to play white wants to
play g5 forcing the knight to h5 and
then he could play Knight to F
or you can't take the night because it's
made in two so this night
combined with g5 might jump to the f4
square or the g3 square so black to play
what do you think black played don't all
shout out at once oh hold on rook F c8
pardon me it's white to play white to
play I apologize
let's see did I do it right yet he just
played rook F white to play rook F c8
was black's last move rook F c8 now this
at the time was a major theoretical
position okay at least it was a position
that I was aware of like my favorite
books my favorite movies I knew this
position inside and out or at least I
thought I did
Karpov played at the time what was
considered a massive theoretical novelty
that is to say he played a new move
nobody had ever played before and I
totally turn foot the scales okay so if
you were white in this position what
would you do
arianna g5 very good very good g5
because this move attacks the knight
threatens to go takes threatening mate
made on h7 Black has no choice he has to
block the h-file now what do you do are
you or Martin what would you do
Knight to g3 or Knight to f4 it's
interchangeable Knight to g3 then after
Knight to g3 okay we can really see what
white wants to do if it was White's turn
he could take with the rook and take
with the night and you've made or you
could take with the night and take with
the rook or the queen and it's going to
be made on h7 but black sacrifices first
rook takes c3 oh dear oh dear what do we
do now what do we do now are you a how
with the night or the rook okay if you
take with the night let's take this pawn
with check force the King to go to b1
now just for fun let's take that night
rook takes h5
well let's happen let's refute rook
takes h5 how can we refute rook takes h5
we can take this pawn with check and
calm down here with a check and come
down here with a check oops will eat the
rook and eventually will checkmate
White's King so that didn't work g5 whoa
whoa the natural move g5 ran into a
counter sacrifice on the Queen side g5
doesn't work it's good for black I need
another suggestion just a second what
about rook d5 how's that for a cool move
yeah isn't that a cool move so if you
take the rook I go check
checkmate so the rook you can't take the
rook the queen is attacked let's say the
Queen drops back Queen to d8 now what
now g5 and now again I have to do the
same thing Knight to g3
and this time I have a different
defensive idea clean f8 since your queen
is trying to checkmate black-black just
gets rid of the trades the Queen's so
one player I was incredibly impressed
with was a man by the name of Michael
bought Vinick and he had analyzed this
game a great length and I think a Soviet
chess magazine at the time called 64 and
he had this position on the board on his
analysis and he says that white stood
slightly better just a smidge
after King g7 ah but it's no checkmating
attack and so that was like that would
have been a success for black that he's
not getting checkmated so these two
tries rook the 5g5 were analyzed and
found less than optimal anatoly karpov
played an absolutely brilliant move that
is really hard to comprehend at first
blush anatoly karpov played the move
rook to d3 and it's sort of like well
what's that well once you see these
variations with g5 Knight h5 Knight g3
rook takes c3 you start to understand
that this rook helps defend
this night and it's preparing the move
g5
okay now Viktor Korchnoi made his one
and only mistake in the whole game yeah
he made his one and only mistake in the
whole game what's a good bad move yeah
well what do you think Viktor Korchnoi
his mistake was what do you think he
played you've been hearing me tell you
that g4 g5 is a big threat by white
right move the knight attack the knight
how can how could black stop g4 g5 yeah
there you go
g5 the problem with g5 from blacks point
of view is that same rotten rook d5 mo
the same rotten luck the fight will get
you every time
how else could black stop g5 come on
guys come on like what does that stop g5
and then you get check David yeah yeah
rook c5 I thought this was a really good
move Wow and you know what does it that
move do the Queen and rook across the
board
first of all rook it stops any of those
tricks that we just saw with rook d5
that's very nice it stops g5 rook takes
G five very nice and I was so impressed
when I saw this move I mean it became
like an instant favorite for me and then
Bob then it gave it a question mark and
said a big mistake and that the only
mistake black makes in the whole game
whoa but from my point of view I thought
this was a really cool idea
black wants to play Bishop to e6
remember when the knight was on d4 the
bishop really didn't want to come to e6
then the black wants to play Bishop e6
Bishop c4 or maybe Bishop e6 Bishop
takes a - in the meantime you can't go
e5 you can't go g5 you can't go f4 what
could white do why was that a mistake
holy cow my rook to d5 okay rook to d5
then it's sort of like strange because
he went rook to d3 first and then rook
to d5 he wanted to do rook to d5 he
could have done it immediately after
rook to d5 Bishop comes to e6 I don't
know what's going on I am by me sorry
Knight d4 ah Knight d4 a very good night
d4 that's like one of those good bad
moves right Knight d4 has a very nice
idea of forking the Queen and the rook
by being able to play Knight b3 but I
will tell you Dragon players will be
very very happy to sacrifice an exchange
and force you to double up your pawns so
that's a pretty good exchange sacrifice
for black are you ready are you ready
for what Anatoly Karpov played Anatoly
Karpov played the most brilliant move i
blacks last move rook c5 was the idea to
stop what threat what threat this is
smooth stop are you as what as well as
g5 correct
g5 whoa wait a minute now you got to
understand Viktor Korchnoi his point of
view he had just played rook to c5 to
stop the guy from playing g5 the guy did
it anyway can you imagine how shocked he
was like whoa what's that rook takes g5
yes yeah whoo that's cool
b4 oh wait a minute maybe we'll forget
about it check don't forget there's a
check in the position Queen a3 check all
right look to d5 where did that now week
what's wrong with Knight takes checkmate
Queen takes h7 check Queen h8 mate so
you can't take the rook with a knight
you have to trade rooks but now after
the rook trade look what happens I'm
threatening Knight takes Issa buck I've
got ideas a knight takes f6 check takes
and check so suddenly blacks King is
under attack White's King is under
attack too but white is coming faster
than black ok the e7 pawn is hanging
what are we going to do we got to defend
we've got to defend the e7 pawn Knight
takes f7 check wolf well first of all
it's Knight takes isse Evan check the
King goes into the corner we take the
rook and that will be threatening Queen
f8 check ooh that would be really really
horrible so Korchnoi defended his pawn
rook e8 now
now what did white do and okay so how
many of you like to take the night don't
all raise your hands at once very good
then
Martin needed your support so if we take
the night takes takes and then how do we
follow up what's our next term take that
pawn with check the king is running like
rabbit you're running like a rabbit yeah
and now what's our next turn yes
Knight f4 so now with our knight on f4
yes it very very often happens that in a
lot of these cases were white as
castling queenside he often plays the
move king b1 what Grand Master's say
tucking the King away because in this
position not only is the a to pawn
hanging when the Kings on cease at c1 it
oftentimes gets caught and on this c1
diagonal and well blacks king is no
longer getting checkmated let us just
put it that way that black is fine
whether we're the white plays Queen h6
check forcing the trade of Queens or
queen h2 black is no longer getting
checkmated so instead of capturing right
away Anatoly Karpov reinforced his
attack he brought this Knight to f4
right away okay so this Knight basically
wants to take the place of its colleague
you basically white wants to take this
Knight
take this pawn with check check again
and when the King is here check again
with this Knight so night ef4 marvelous
move and black played bishop to see
six to stop this night from coming here
what did white do what did white do ah
brilliant idea I like it very much thank
you very much for that idea how about
this this is a very typical tactical
attack winning attack Knight takes f6
check G takes f6 Knight h5 and when your
eye first sees this idea you think this
is really really wonderful White's idea
is he threatens maiden one if you take
the knight he wants to give check move
the King and mate on g7 you sorry Queen
and not yet Queen Queen g5 right away oh
it's check and what of it drew what
dragon players love they live for such
moments where oftentimes they're in
exchange down with a double pawn but
what happens is this mass of pawns here
this 4 versus 2 it can quickly be a
position that turns into blacks favor
black gets the black gets a nice pawn
storm passers and often time they're
supported by the both the King as well
as the bishop in any case the checkmate
threats have gone and then it's a crazy
ending who's better
I'm not sure that black is worse so
we'll go back to this position this is a
very hard yes young ham
Bravo outstanding congratulations if
there was an Oscar prize
you'd be receiving the Oscar
unfortunately the Oscars well what can I
say
e5 double exclamation mark so the idea
is that you want to cut this black queen
from coming across the fifth-ranked you
can't take the night with a night
because of check and mate if you take
the pawn on e5 then that variation we
just showed works like a charm there's
no Queen g5 in view of the threat of
Queen g7 mate or takes and rook G one
comes over mate lacks lost black can't
do this Viktor Korchnoi therefore
captured the knight Bishop takes d5 and
now what should white do Bravo take the
knight yes now hold on
be careful let me just warn you that if
it was black to move there'd be a nasty
rook e1 check to deal with you don't
want to deal with that one sorry Queen
takes pawn check very good
very good are you
precisely Knight takes d5 Queen takes
defy ooh
Korchnoi actually resigned after Knight
takes d5 because he realized after Queen
takes d5 rook e1 he's losing his rook
with Shaq and maybe more yes please yes
check right so if you okay sorry let me
do that again let's say for argument's
sake if you move the King here then I
take the pawn with check and I take the
rook yet so if you right so you have to
move to the 8th now I take this pawn
with check the King has to move to c8
now black has two threats
his major major threat is rook e1 and
his secondary threat is Knight c3 Queen
c3 check and forces the trade either
Queen c3 check or even Knight c3 both
deal very nicely with both threats and
white emerges a piece ahead did I mean
was that not a brilliant game can we
give credit that Wow
well I tell you that game made a very
powerful impression on my mind and I
after studying this game I started
studying a lot of Anatoly carve house
games because he played perfectly and
there was only one mistake from Viktor
Korchnoi after this game Viktor Korchnoi
basically gave up the dragon he stopped
playing it it was such a painful loss